So I'm notoriously disorganized when it
comes to money and paying bills and
personal finance in general.
I have no good reason for it.
Only to say that if left to my own
devices,
I'd only ever read things and learn
things and write things and make videos
like this in respect to my greater
happiness.
The only value money has is to give me
the freedom to do the things I like in
itself.
Money to me is worthless.
And maybe that's the reason why I
neglect it so much because it's time
consuming and tedious and boring.
And clerical.
I mean,
just to take a look.
Take a look at this.
Let me show you this right here.
Perfect Metaphor for what I'm talking
about.
So here's a book of,
uh,
the philosophy of nature.
I've just been catching up on a little
bit of nature as you do.
And as a bookmark,
this is absolutely real.
We have some macy's builts,
a Geico bill.
Here's one.
Here's a special one we got here.
Ah Ha.
Wells Fargo.
Ah Yes.
The title to my car.
Check this out.
I mean,
is that a system or what?
So today I've resolved to build a system
for myself to become more organized in
this regard,
and there's only one place to go when
you have a problem,
but you didn't know this.
When I.
Staples was my first job.
I worked work area when I was a senior
in high school for six months.
I don't know if they're going to let
first item.
We need three ring binder.
What color do we like here?
What color is chartreuse?
Perhaps?
Item number two.
File folders.
Okay.
Item number three,
we got binder clips.
Last item,
magnifying class.
Just kidding.
One of these desperate calculator so
that you look really cool and that
people in the other rooms know that
you're deadly serious about finance item
for two sharpies.
Okay?
Make three ring binder holes in your
folders.
First step.
Okay,
so got all the bills for my decks,
all the other extra stuff that's been
mixing with it.
First thing we're gonna do is take these
folders that I hope punch 12 of them.
Get that back.
We're going to write every month of the
year on 12 volts.
Get it DSL.
Your reference.
Yeah,
you're freaking out right now about how
cool.
Now
take our folders marks with the months
and put them into the binder.
Get a macy's bill here for April.
Okay,
so here's what we're going to go to the
month of April and take one of our.
Find a rings here.
Dog thinks that these are snacks and
toys would.
You shouldn't feed your dog binders.
The binder clips.
If we hadn't paid this,
macy's built the system would be to
stick to clip it to the back of the
envelope.
That means it's not paid.
Now,
once we do pay it and I just didn't pay
this,
kind of throw it in the inside and we're
good to go.
So we're going to do that to all these
bills right now.
Okay,
so we're all done.
All the bills are in here.
And the 2012 binder,
we got all the paid bills in the folders
and what's not paid.
We got attached to the back to be sent
in the mail.
Looking good organization.
Item number five,
60 quarter coin rappers just for the
hell of it.
Binder clips.
Item number 3:15
here.
That'll be just switch it up.